[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce nouveau numéro de place publique
la martinique ses plages son sable chaud
un tableau paradisiaque entachée par une
radicalisation de la délinquance car ils
sont de plus en plus jeunes à commettre
des délits
du simple cambriolage aux braquages avec
armes ont pas de vingt mille armes
illégales en circulation en martinique
mythe ou réalité place publique vous
propose ce soir
ces parcours de vie impétueux rocailleux
engluée dans le tunnel de la délinquance
mais dont la porte de sortie demeure
entrouvert c'est un magazine signé sans
gaffe à gours marque france quoi quels
mots et olivier auguste
selon certaines études elle serait la
préoccupation première des martiniquais
au même rang que le chômage la
délinquance dans deynile mais son
omniprésence conduit parfois à sa
banalisation ou à une forme de fatalisme
pourtant les chiffres ne mentent pas la
martinique se classe 4ème région de
france la plus violente et les faits
commis avec arme
ils sont dix fois plus élevé que dans
l'hexagone une violence que certains
n'hésitent pas à mettre en scène de
manière décomplexée et valorisante des
fictions servant sur un plateau d'argent
de nouveaux codes aux jeunes cerveaux en
formation mais les maisons encore les
conséquences souvent tragique est bien
réelle de cette violence
[Musique]
6 heures du matin des hommes encagoulés
progresse dans la pénombre d'une cité du
sud de l'île leurs cibles se trouvent
dans les étages de cet immeuble jeune
homme accusé de braquage à main armée
l'assaut est donné
[Musique]
en quelques secondes la cible est
neutralisé deux enfants sont emmenés à
l'écart au point que d'enfants au bout
de plus madame les proches de la victime
sont partagés entre tristesse et colère
mais pour les hommes de l'antenne gign
pas de temps à perdre un autre objectif
réside à quelques kilomètres de là ils
craignent qu'ils ne soient prévenus de
leur intervention par des complices une
crainte vite confirmée à leur arrivée la
cible qui tentaient de s'échapper a déjà
été interpellé par d'autres gendarmes en
planque face à l'imposant dispositif le
jeune homme en tee shirt blanc n'oppose
pas de résistance et coopèrent la scène
se passe au milieu d'enfants en pleurs
et de parents désabusés qui tentent de
les consoler
lorsque les hommes de l'antenne ggn de
martinique interviennent c'est en
général au profit d'individus considérés
comme dangereux
au total trois hommes ont été
interpellés ce matin là tous suspectés
de braquage à main armée commis en
décembre
[Musique]
les armes à feu un fléau qui ne cesse
d'enfler en martinique
impossible de savoir combien il en
circule mais les saisies d'armes donne
une idée de l'ampleur du phénomène
nous sommes à l'armurerie de la
gendarmerie dans ces bacs une centaine
d'armes saisies en six mois seulement en
fort de france et lamentin des armes de
poing mais aussi des fusils des pôles
très souvent modifiées exemple d'une
arme qui a été modifié donc on parle
d'une arme qui étant à la base en un
fini mat à blanc et qui a été modifié
avec canon percée est également modifié
au niveau du bar rayé avec un rajout de
matières et percé pour pouvoir permettre
le tyran 22 long rifle voilà c'est plus
dangereux c'est plus dangereux tout à
fait donc pour cette arme lors on prêt
vous avez le cas la modification
beaucoup plus facile en fait vous avez
juste un raccourcissement de canon et
raccourcissement de cross voilà qui est
beaucoup plus pratique beaucoup plus
discret qu'on peut mettre dans une
voiture qui passe un peu plus inaperçu
quelquefois également elles sont
fabriquées de manière totalement
artisanale fabrication artisanale où on
part de tubes vraiment simple à la base
ayez avec une installation avec à une
station de percuteur au niveau du culot
ça fait comme un système de mortier et
vous pouvez tirer du calibre 12
en couvrant coup par coup c'est pas prêt
si c'est pas du long terme ça peut
marcher
une fois deux fois trois fois la
quatrième fois ça marchera pas en tout
cas ce sont des hommes qui peuvent te
cedeao qui peuvent tuer mais on trouve
aussi des copies d'armes de guerre comme
ce pistolet mitrailleur saisis dans une
affaire de stups des termes là donc
c'est finalement 22 long rifle donc à
répétition qui est donc une copie du hem
cat américain utilisé par les soldats
américains
c'est une arme dangereuse par son
calibre et par par son fonctionnement et
ses 6 également
c'est à dire vous pouvez tirer on
pouvait tirs en rafale
des armes à feu qui font régulièrement
la une de l'actualité
et si dans les médias un drame en chasse
un autre et le pousse dans l'oubli pour
les victimes et leurs familles ce sont
des destins brisés et des vie qui
bascule
il y à bientôt cinq ans leonid a perdu
l'un de ses fils bruno décédé au cours
d'une fusillade d'une extrême violence
c'était au quartier la démarche achète
cher au cours d'un anniversaire
il était alors âgé de 21 ans tirait
qu'on est malade comme un autre match
quoi ils tiraient cibler des cambodgiens
il tirait comme ça il tenait à rome
comme ceux qui possèdent boum boum comme
ça bon meeting tout ce qui bougeait
[Rires]
[Musique]
où
aujourd'hui les photos du jeune homme
recouvre les murs du petit appartement
où elle vit avec son autre office et son
petit fils
et c'est toujours aussi douloureux on
dit que le temps avec le temps à la
douleur s'est facilement je peux dire
est que tant la douleur s'agrandit
s'agrandit ce complément là qu'on
appelle seulement quelques les
cimetières de leur jeu même quand tous
les jours pour pouvoir parler avec lui
qu avec lui et puis on essayait de
comprendre toujours si je vais pas les
jours je vous assure que je ne vis pas
mais fois elle et tout laisse à petit
tous les amis de la lumière pour lui m
il faut
sur cette voie
mais j'ai dit on me dit qu'il faut pas
le dire mais je le dis je des cma froid
je demande pardon at jusque jeudi de
punir de lait d'oeufs de lait tous
mentent et l'esprit ceux qui ont fait ça
vous allez dès que je suis dur d'aller
tourmenté désormais chez dormir de les
empêcher de vie le procès s'est tenu en
février 2010 est le tireur a écopé de 15
ans de réclusion
quatre ans dont deux avec sursis pour
celui qui a servi de chauffeur
mais sur les huit individus dont font
état certains témoins seuls deux ont
comparu devant la cour d'assises et
quatre ans ce que j'allais vous à libre
grande partie leur moto je les voie
libre tous les jours
il habite y habite toujours je vous
assure que la colère savant tous les
jours tous les jours et tous les jours
et tous les jours un drame qui a aussi
conduit à l'éclatement de la famille
même en famille même envers fou vous
devenu la bête noire de kpn de son fils
envers la famille envers tout le monde
avait le travail envers tous de 6 ans s
5 la famille pour la famille si votre
fils aimant c'est parce que c'est
presque à cause de vous
c'est parce que à cause de vous alors
moi je vous dis que je me suis retiré de
tout le monde est bon en vrai bonheur
c'est mon petit fils depuis leonid a
aussi perdu son emploi à trois pieds
étaient des résidences que je travaille
depuis 26 ans
il a demandé au médecin du travail que
j'étais paul savoie et des courriers
beaucoup de coûts liés aux métiers de
travail
le métier a dit que j'étais à travailler
et malgré tout immo l'essentiel au motif
réel et sérieux
oui c'est mon petit fils c'est maladroit
2006 mon petit fils servi beau cadeau
que lui avait données oui
suffit à huy
[Musique]
[Rires]
lors de la fusillade le cousin de bruno
à lui était blessé quatre jours de coma
et un mois hospitalisé à priori une
chance
en réalité le début d'un long chemin de
quoi
[Musique]
je sais plus pas mal de dix opérations
par plus des opérations de dix opéras
réputé 10 opérations
j'ai eu des complications quelle
complication
il ya eu des infections dues à l'hôpital
il ya eu voilà il ya une le temps ça
prend du temps
j'ai eu le moal asio des fois vraiment
je souhaite à fin mai marché qui mon
fils je ne sais pas ça parce que si
vraiment c'est vraiment dur à ne pas
dormir tout ce monde sans doute parce
qu'on a mal parce qu'on a mal en étant
pouvoir une mini c'est souvent à ne pas
savoir aussi si dell on va pouvoir
marcher l'homme a été touché au ventre
sa dernière opération remonte à
septembre 2017 soit quatre ans après les
faits toutes ces années il a porté une
poche pour évacuer ses selles parce
qu'elles ont la cote je ne sais pas si
c'est parce que partout où vous allez
vous avez ici
vous imaginez-vous mai
je sais pas moi vous attache vous mais
avec un pied et vous devrez à l'épaule
thouaré que ça vous imaginez pas facile
mais par la lame est pas mal en pis si
ma fille ou juillet la cinq ans avant de
bonne heure et demie avec un à cinq ans
son premier demi avec son fait à cinq
ans c'est pan-allemand il ya plein de
choses bon déjà quelque chose que je
mange pas je suis de montrer si fort
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile des
fois j'avais une magie des choses
dix fois j'y voyais j&j ferment au
tennis est obligé de rester chez moi des
difficultés physiques qui entraîne peu à
peu une exclusion sociale
pas de sortie pas de travail le jeune
homme ce sont les et on se présente
demain patron il faut aller consommer
comme on dit
on pour le médical médicaments consommés
dans une visite médicale et que le
docteur du travail voir ma situation
vous imaginez bien qu'il va pas il va
pas me donner sa part favori pour moi
ouais moi je n'ai plus gérer
premièrement tout tout soin de mettre en
prison
il nie et ceux qui sont prises au pour
moi me ils sont limités
pourquoi premièrement parce que quand
ils sont en prison
ils ont soit une formation soit il un
boulot kg atteint ils sont ils sont bien
mais moi entre 2010 au générique c'est
obligé de me lever le matin pour
chercher une formation alors eu
l'information vienne a eu un vrai pour
moi ils sont mus que moi je suis une
victime c'est environ
[Musique]
pour tenter de contenir le phénomène des
armes à feu les autorités ont lancé il
ya quatre ans l'opération déposer les
armes sorte d'armistice judiciaire qui
consiste à inciter des propriétaires
d'armes à se débarrasser de leurs biens
sans risque de poursuites
300 armes à feu ont ainsi été saisis en
2015 plus de deux cents en 2017
mais dans ce domaine la lutte passe
aussi par la présence sur le terrain
[Musique]
22h début de patrouille mouvementée pour
les hommes de la bac la brigade
anticriminalité cet homme a tenté de se
soustraire à un simple contrôle avec son
scooter il a heurté la voiture de police
la plaque de l'engin était dissimulé qui
avait cette motocyclette dont la plaque
d'immatriculation était
maquillée et après un refus d'obtempérer
donc a foncé sur le véhicule
administratif est monsieur individus
interpellés pas le nez c'est quand nous
sommes arrivés au club un sort aux
alentours les esprits s'échauffent
les policiers doivent quitter les lieux
rapidement on est obligé de réagir très
vite
[Musique]
les individus qui sont à proximité
si on fait pas frob ont commencé à
lancer des bouteilles ou essayer
d'extirper
dora nuit
[Musique]
l'homme sera placé en garde à vue où il
devra expliquer son geste
mais la bac de nuit n'est pas la seule
force de sécurité à veiller sur force de
france ce soir aux terres sainville les
hommes du gan
le groupe d'appui de nuit font leurs
patrouilles habituelles avec ses
prostituées ses bars et ses animations
c'est de loin le quartier le plus animé
des nues foyalaise en général c'est que
cette intervention sur ce qui touche à
la au tapage la roaco la constitution
man les x
il ya les soins dès qu'on fait partie
des quartiers vous êtes plus souvent
peut on dire à 80
80 % à m
mais les policiers ont aussi dans leur
zone lamentin comme ici au quartier four
à chaux ou comme souvent dès leur
arrivée un homme a pris la fuite à la
vue des policiers ces derniers procèdent
à une inspection rapide des lieux la
cocaïne conditionnés dans des biens sur
un autre rond quand on voit la tangente
donc des fois on s'organise il ya un
véhicule mais c'est de manquer pour
essayer de contrôler un maximum de
personnes
cette fois ci les policiers ne trouvant
pas d'armes mais pour le seul mois de
janvier ils en ont saisi plus d'une
dizaine comme ce pistolet beretta ont
retrouvé quelques heures plus tôt suite
à une affaire de vol à main armée
[Musique]
quelques jours après les policiers
reviennent en force dans le même
quartier des effectifs de la police aux
frontières de la police municipale et la
compagnie départementale d'intervention
sont mobilisés des chiens renifleurs
également ils ne sont pas venus pour
rien et j'ai apprécié la petite boîte en
dessous de la tôle la tôle avec le
couteau qui sert à découper bien sûr et
voilà ce qu'il en résulte de la résine
de cannabis mais aussi de la cocaïne
les individus contrôlés ont visiblement
tout l'attirail des petits trafiquants
de drogue
hydroxy y en a ce sac c'est au sac de 10
leur équipe et en os transporter de la
drogue
avec une particularité c'est qu'il ya
quand même de la lui au centre d'essien
détectives amateurs de vol ou de
transformation du malawi
[Musique]
face à cette délinquance souvent armés
les forces de police renouvelle
régulièrement le rationnel dissuasif ici
un pistolet 9 mm automatique qui ne sert
donc lors de nos missions transport de
fonds assurent une sécurité de bâtiments
ou alors intervention face à des
individus lourdement armés et nous avons
cette arme là qui est un
hk g36 donc c'est du calibre 5,56 chaque
année tous les fonctionnaires de police
doivent effectuer au moins trois séances
de tir
c'est une obligation à fort de france
les forces de l'ordre bénéficie depuis
plusieurs années maintenant de précieux
soutiens 60 caméras de surveillance
contrôlable à distance qui filme 24
heures sur 24 dans ce centre de
visionnage dont le lieu est tenu secret
des agents se relaient pour identifier
toute infraction délit un dispositif qui
a fait ses preuves et qui gênent la
délinquance comme auteur sa ville pour
les quartiers d'été à saint vil qui est
un quartier très sensible effectivement
nous utilisons
ce qui nous reste comme caméra je dis
bien nous en avons mais malheureusement
comme c'est je veux vous dire quartiers
sensibles bien entendu des caméras et
gêne beaucoup les les délinquants qui
sont sur place et elles sont souvent
vandalisés soit ce sont des impacts de
balles que nous trouvons sur nous sur
des caméras impact de mal ou encore des
projectiles de toutes sortes de
projectiles et il y en a même qui arriva
les déconnecter puisqu'il arrive à
trouver l'endroit où il ya
l'alimentation
électrique pour les nostalgiques open
sur les douze caméras implantées aux
terres sainville près de la moitié sont
hors d'usagé
malgré des remplacements récurrent
souvent décrit par ceux qui s'y livrent
comme un engrenage le circuit de la
délinquance autorise pourtant des portes
de sortie dans une petite ruelle du
quartier sainte-thérèse à fort-de-france
l'école de la deuxième chance
les élèves qui se retrouvent viciant
pour la plupart parcours en lien avec la
délinquance certains d'entre eux sont
même sous contrôle judiciaire ou dans
des cas extrêmes bénéficie
d'autorisations de sortie avant de
retourner en prison le soir ici sont
dispensés des cours de rattrapage en
français mathématiques langues vivantes
mais la formation portent aussi sur le
savoir être
mais qu'il rentre il peut voir la
différence entre ce qui est acceptable
dans un milieu professionnel et ce qui
ne l'est pas et juste à côté il a un
miroir où il peut comparer sa propre
tenue avec ce ce qui est préconisé en
milieu professionnel le oui est ce qui
n'est pas gris ce qui n'est pas
acceptable ça va pas se faire du jour au
lendemain
quelquefois à des jeunes ne peuvent pas
aller faire de shopping tout de suite
allé s'acheter des chaussures qu'il faut
le pantalon qu'il faut on leur laisse le
temps leur fixe des objectifs mais
dans un temps déterminé il doit pouvoir
coller à l'image du professionnel en
entrant dans cette école chaque jeune se
voit attribuer 12 points chaque
comportement inapproprié et sanctionnés
par un retrait au crédit égal à zéro est
synonyme de sanction mais un celi
ça peut être en voie provisoire ou
définitif selon la gravité encore une
fois à des faits mais le but c'est
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à moins de sport
le but c'est quand même même si au
départ c'est un petit peu difficile
qu'ils puissent rattraper des points par
des stages par d
l'été ige ce qu'on appelle étaient
légers travaux d'intérêt général
[Musique]
teddy est une ancienne élève trafic de
cocaïne fusillade braquage à main armée
le jeune homme compte dix sept
condamnations à son casier judiciaire
à 26 ans il a déjà passé huit années de
sa vie en prison
[Musique]
c'est sale c'est latin 10 - de
veauchette quelle gauche touche de
bouche et on est obligé de te voir
après on a fait des poignets c'est une
prison c'est normal il ya des endroits
qui sont complus pillon mais du cross
s'est pas mis les doigts qui sont soit
c'est assez chaud je vois pas être je
suis native et d'arrivée hier et qui va
venir te dire j'aime votre paire de
baskets tu vois tout de suite
saadé a appelé ses yeux il veut taper le
basket ça fait déjà deux nuls à eelv on
y voit pas sa femme il n'a pas de neige
tu viens d'être en plus instables de
chaussures ça va déjà appelé à ses yeux
il va tenue tu as peu de conteuse
chaussures cet après midi je passe point
d'un moment tu es jeune tu réfléchis
qu'est ce que tu vas faire qu'est-ce que
tu toi tout ccsaat voix et puis la
plupart déjà dit ça c'est bon je suis en
prison mais je suis là comme un fou de
manif on ne sait pas intervenu à cuba
téléphone si vous devez vous défendre
mais il a soulevé un même travail mais
avec la pure comme il va affronter des
fonds moi au début j'étais tu vois quand
son entrée en prison c'était ok découper
ses 18 mois jusqu'à vaisseau timide tu
vois je pensais même pas c'est à toi que
j'ai fait 3 1 4 il trouve que je vois ma
fille une fois comme ça dia non là c'est
trop dur je vois voici ma mère qui vient
des fois je vois ma mais au plus haut
pour l'occasion pour qu'on te lâche pas
tacher personne du roi il a fait une
grosse peine tu peux faire tout ce que
tu veux
pourquoi c'est pas bien ça va terminer
le pont à la loupe tous sont obligés de
pi3c c'est obligé c'est comme ça que ça
se passe
[Musique]
vous allez dire vers le fossé nuit
combien des touristes qui sont en train
de se baigner pour qu'on puisse pas des
piqués et qui leur sac depuis un an et
demi
teddy a entamé une impressionnante
métamorphose
après plusieurs mois passés à l'école de
la deuxième chance
il souhaite à présent travailler dans la
médiation et les choses semblent bien
engagées
au terme de ce stage de moi avec les
agences spécialisées de fort de france
teddy espère bien décrocher un contrat
j'aime parler j'aime dialoguer avec les
jeux qui sont difficulté tout ça des
fois que je vois des sdf je parle avec
et je vois qu'il écoute ça donne du
courage ça donne du baume au coeur parce
qu'avant il est classé dans l'écouteur
on me voit comme un délinquant je vois
que j'arrivais à fait autre chose de ma
vie pour me tuer le match quand j'ai
fait celui là c'est celui là que je veux
et je sais que dans celui là si on
continue je sais que à de la glace du
seigneur
how do vale monde
[Musique]
et
mathias boris anderson et blanchard sont
eux de nouveaux arrivants tous ont été
d'une manière ou d'une autre dans la
délinquance certains comme mathias sont
même passés par la case prison pour
braquage à main armée le jeune homme de
21 ans est sous contrôle judiciaire
j'ai fait des oies kg à gauche et des
gens le truc ça commence toujours pour
un petit fils ouais c'est avec les âmes
et qu'on est gamin on entend déjà parler
des gants de ceux ci la manaudou nous
qu'on ait enfin et ses doigts pour dieu
qu'ils veulent on va commencer par aller
voler la boutique et comprend des titres
qu'on va montrer son tricot année ça
c'est la base de tout enfant qui vit
temps si tu sais vous voyez ou bien dans
des corps chez si une balle est bien au
fait nos moments ça devient disons 8
chez huawei on y donne un vieux cercle
vicieux
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait aussi à
prendre conscience de certaines choses
de la vie plus ou moins après faire à sa
tête son 16e point c'est compliqué et
puis parce que tu vas en tout séduit
pourtant de l'année déficit voilà je
suis de ne pas les moyens je n'avance
pas
[Musique]
vous voulez pas braquer des gens au
début je voulais juste par exemple
défenseur lui qui voulait se faire
braquer pour un gars qui est juste pas
ils voulaient profiter on va dire je
vois que moi je pouvais le défendre je
le faisais pour la suite
c'était ce qu'il voulait me montrer qu'
il était plus fort n'est portée - je
leur montre que moi aussi par n'importe
quel moyen pour leur montrer que je peux
faire n'importe quoi aussi j'ai touché
beaucoup de choses voilà je faisais ça
parce que j'avais rien dans ma poche je
voulais avoir de l'argent j'ai pas connu
des anniversaires comme les autres qu'on
les hauts faits de les donner des
cadeaux tout et tout j'ai pas qu'une
même la nouvelle j'ai pas eu de cadeau
pour noël
donc moi même je voulais avoir mes
affaires donc j'essaie aller voler pour
les awa quand je me regarde dans un
miroir je me suis dit waouh pour gagner
une voiture que j'ai volé qu'est-ce que
je peux faire avec
je peux même pas la route et c'est
difficile d'échapper à cela
en citer l'argent facile les trafics de
drogue ouais tu es un exemple tu es là
tu es d'autres portables tout ça on voit
que j'arrive de vos toilettes à
l'intérieur avant tout ça c'est des
trucs que il se plaît à citer ils sont
réputés pour ça non plus ça va toujours
avec des soutes la récup a fui you ça
qu'on vous voyez que la mère doit payer
le loyer aller tout seul là ça empire à
saper tout ça c'est tout ça mais a pris
la relève a jamais parlé d'argent c'est
toi c'est moi région moi je dépose de
l'argent dans les sacs de ma mère parce
que je sais que demain va jamais bonne
pour la chamade amadeus a tapissé par
jean minot fossat qui voit aujourd'hui
tout semble avoir pris du recul sur leur
vécu
mais même lorsque l'on veut faire amende
honorable
difficile d'échapper à son passé depuis
on va dire des paires 2012 ma vie a
complètement changé et pour blanc
problème problème justice ont frappé à
ma porte
ah mais si vous avez essayé opposés a
reconnu convocation beaucoup de
convocation au tribunal tout et tout il
faut que je change d'avis cette vie là
c'est pas moi je ne me reconnais pas
dans ça j'ai pas ma place dans sa va
placer quelqu'un qui va à l'école qui va
à point avoir un diplôme
pourquoi je ne peux pas avoir un diplôme
pourquoi je peux pas travailler
légalement un des jeunes qui ne sont pas
qui se donne pas les moyens non plus
parce que tout ça on est là se prennent
à la ccim a pas 4 ou du travail mais il
est à moi j'ai eu des mots toujours des
voitures ok bon cette nostalgie concours
des permis mais c'est parce qu'ils
m'empêchent de ne pas reconnaître ce
matin que deux du domaine de mon dieu
que je sais gré des allées faire tel
papier et faire ça après sincèrement
c'est pas du jour au lendemain que j'ai
à faire c'est assez logique du jeu le
monde certes mais quand tu n'as pas ça
il ya autre chose c'est l'ambition oies
et l'ambition fait beaucoup de choses
qu'on a de l'ambition
ah bin là on sort ou en question prend
du recul sur certains joueurs aient
procédé canon j'avoue battre comme
le maintien
[Musique]
l'école de la deuxième chance est
soumise à une obligation de résultat 50
% de sorties positives minimum
c'est-à-dire débouchant sur une
formation qualifiante pour le contrat
d'au moins trois mois
l'an dernier c'était le cas pour 50
dépensant des élèves
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce numéro de
place publique on se retrouve très vite
à bientôt
[Musique]